hey this is chris scott from bravo's top
chef and we're making pepper pot shrimp
[Music]
so there's a couple ways where you can
mince garlic you can either do it with a
knife or you just chop
you know and then cut again or there's
another way that i like to use where you
can take the same piece of garlic take a
fork and mince it on the edge of the
fork and then you'll notice how your
pieces of garlic is nice and smooth
already now let's move on to the okra a
lot of people don't like okra because
they don't like the sliminess but there
is one way that you can avoid that as
you cut it you can put it in a bowl of
iced salt water and what that does is
just kind of decreases the amount of
slime that comes out when you're cooking
it you know everybody always talks about
cooking with their grandmother and i was
raised by my grandmother and my mother
so a lot of the times my grandmother
would always be cooking that's where i
kind of got the inspiration the one
thing about the way that i cook a lot of
the techniques are passed along from
from my family so there's nothing
extremely fancy about it it just comes
from a good place and it's all about
love
scotch bonnet peppers one of the hottest
peppers on the planet you don't want to
make the mistake and cut them without
gloves and then rub your face or
accidentally go to the bathroom or it is
that you know what i'm saying so have a
glove one i'm i'm just going to put one
in there i grew up kind of right in the
middle of pennsylvania dutch country and
philadelphia so you kind of have the
influence of frank's lime soda philly
cheese steaks soft pretzels and on the
other side shoofly pie chow chow whoopee
pies so my cuisine is kind of like a mix
of both but i also throw in the history
of the cuisine of people of color so
it's important to drizzle in the corn
meal if you dump it in it'll create one
huge clump and you'll have lumps it
takes time but in the end your finished
product is so much better this dish it's
a play on the guyanese dish pepper pot
oxtail and pepper pot oxtail is a
christmas time dish in the caribbean
what's important is that even though
you're trying to simplify a dish you
still want to stay true to its roots you
still want to be able to build the
flavors just don't skimp on technique on
top chef we had to do the dish in 30
minutes or less back at the restaurant
when you're making the actual sauce it
takes an hour and a half or so the jerk
spice is really gonna bring out a lot of
those caribbean flavors it's spicy
it has a lot of like really great herbs
all of those flavors will grow as this
dish comes to life some of the best
people that i've ever met and had the
opportunity to meet and work with were
right there with me on top chef you kind
of get into a routine of doing what it
is that you do all the time i actually
went and started at a couple friends
restaurants back in philadelphia just to
get used to being in a different kitchen
used to doing different food once i hit
the ground in denver i was all set and i
definitely recommend that for anybody
who's going to be on top chef in the
future i'm just about finished but right
before i plate i'm going to check for
seasoning make sure that it's exactly
where i want to be what's certainly
important is your balance between the
sweet and salty in a case like this
because you're adding a lot of natural
sweet vegetables and then the jerk kind
of takes it a different route the sugar
what you might think is going to make it
sweet what that does is just create more
of a balance so you're not tasting
sweetness as in a dessert you're tasting
balance
let's give it a try
you